Over the past few years, the number and variety of cannabis products available to American consumers has soared. Recreational marijuana use is now legal in 19 states and the District of Columbia, and it has been decriminalized in 12 others. Medical marijuana use is legal in 37 states plus D.C. Meanwhile, other cannabis products, such as CBD and CBG are available in oils, candies, lotions, and mure. Myriad other products sold everywhere from dispensaries to gas stations. Americans are taking advantage of this new availability. An August Gallup poll found that 16% of adults currently smoke marijuana, up from 11% in 2013,
在过去几年里，美国消费者可获得的大麻产品在数量和种类上都出现了激增。目前，娱乐性大麻的使用在19个州和哥伦比亚特区是合法的，在另外12个州已实现非刑事化。医用大麻在37个州和哥伦比亚特区是合法的。与此同时，其他大麻产品，如CBD（大麻二酚）和CBG（大麻萜酚），已以油、糖果、乳液等形式面市。从大麻药房到加油站，随处可见各种各样的产品。美国人正在利用这种新的可获得性。盖洛普8月份的一项民意调查发现，目前有16%的成年人吸食大麻，高于2013年的11%。
and 14% say they consume marijuana edibles. Amid this rapidly changing landscape, researchers are exploring both the risks and the potential health benefits of cannabis, aiming to make sure that the science catches up to the policy changes and the marketplace. So what are cannabinoids and how do they act on our brain and body? What are the differences among THC, CBD, CBG, and the other cannabinoids on the market? What potential do cannabinoids have to help treat anxiety, ease pain, and address a long list of other maladies?
另有14%的人表示他们食用大麻食品。在这种快速变化的环境中，研究人员正在探索大麻的风险和潜在的健康益处，旨在确保科学研究能够跟上政策变化和市场发展的步伐。那么，什么是大麻素？它们如何作用于我们的大脑和身体？THC（四氢大麻酚）、CBD、CBG以及市场上其他大麻素之间有什么区别？大麻素在帮助治疗焦虑、缓解疼痛以及解决一系列其他疾病方面具有什么潜力？
And on the risk side, is marijuana dangerous? Is it addictive? What's its relationship to do? schizophrenia and other mental health disorders. And what does the research say about CBD, CBG, and other substances that sometimes fall in a legal gray area? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Ziva Cooper, director of the UCLA Center for Keele, Center for
在风险方面，大麻危险吗？它会让人上瘾吗？它与精神分裂症及其他心理健康障碍有什么关系？关于CBD、CBG以及其他有时处于法律灰色地带的物质，研究是怎么说的？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是加州大学洛杉矶分校（UCLA）大麻和大麻素中心主任、UCLA大卫·格芬医学院精神病学与生物行为科学系副教授齐瓦·库珀博士。她拥有密歇根大学生物生理学博士学位。她通过双盲和安慰剂对照研究，研究大麻和大麻素的治疗潜力和可能的副作用。她的一些项目包括研究男女对大麻素反应的差异，以及探索THC和CBD缓解疼痛的潜力。库珀博士还曾在国家科学院大麻健康影响委员会任职，该委员会于2017年发布了一份关于该主题的有影响力的报告。她是数十篇同行评审期刊研究的作者，并经常
cannabis and cannabinoids and an associate professor in the Department of Psychiatry and Biobbehavioral Sciences at UCLA's David Geffen School of Medicine. She holds a PhD in biophysiology from the University of Michigan. She studies both the therapeutic potential and the possible adverse effects of cannabis and cannabinoids through double-blind and placebo-controlled studies. Some of her projects include looking at differences between men's and women's responses to cannabinoids and exploring the potential for THC and CBD to ease pain. Dr. Cooper also served on the National Academies of Sciences Committee on the Health Effects of Cannabis, which released an influential report on the topic in 2017. She is author of dozens of studies in peer-reviewed journals and speaks
在媒体上谈论大麻和大麻素的研究。感谢您今天参加我的节目，库珀博士。金，非常感谢。很高兴来到这里。刚才在介绍中我提到了几种大麻素，大麻、CBD、CBG。那么，让我们先弄清楚这些东西到底是什么。今天市面上主要的大麻产品有哪些？它们之间有什么区别？它们叫什么？太好了。这是一个很好的开场问题。本质上，什么是大麻，这些不同的产品又是什么？大麻植物，如果含有一定量的Delta-9 THC，有时被称为大麻（marijuana）。THC是大麻植物中主要的致幻成分。
frequently to the media about cannabis and cannabinoid research. Thank you for joining me today, Dr. Cooper. Kim, thank you so much. It's wonderful to be here. I mentioned several types of cannabinoids in the intro a minute ago, marijuana, CBD, CBG. So let's start by getting straight what all these things are. What are the main cannabis products available today? What are the differences among them? What are they called? Great. This is a wonderful question to start out with. Essentially, what is cannabis and what are these different products? And so the cannabis plant, which is sometimes called marijuana, if it has a certain amount of Delta 9 THC in it. So THC is the primary intoxicating component of the cannabis plant.
大麻。然后我们还有工业大麻（hemp），它也是大麻的一种，但工业大麻中只含有极少量的THC。在这种大麻植物中，无论你指的是工业大麻还是大麻，都有数百种不同的化学物质构成了这种植物。其中一些化学物质是大麻植物所特有的，我们将这些独特的化学物质称为植物大麻素。你之前提到过其中的一些植物大麻素。简而言之，我们称它们为大麻素，因为“植物大麻素”这个词说起来太拗口了。
Marijuana. And then we also have hemp, which is also cannabis, but hemp has less a very small amount of THC in it. And in this cannabis plant, whether you're talking about hemp or marijuana, there's over hundreds of different chemicals that comprise this plant. Some of these chemicals are unique to the cannabis plant, and we refer to those unique chemicals as phytocannabinoids. You mentioned some of these phyto-canabinoids before. In short, we call them cannabinoids because phyto-canabinoids can be too cumbersome to say.
所以，再说一次，最广为人知的植物大麻素之一是Delta-9 THC，简称THC。同样，这是大麻植物中导致人们使用大麻时产生“快感”的成分，但它也被认为具有治疗效果，我相信我们会在本次会议中讨论这一点。人们知道的另一种大麻素是CBD，即大麻二酚。我们确实开始看到它的受欢迎程度在上升。事实上，我不会说我们开始看到它的受欢迎程度在上升，它现在就很受欢迎。它之所以如此受欢迎，部分原因在于与THC不同，它不会让人产生幻觉，而且有几个迹象表明它可能具有治疗作用，
So, again, one of the most popularly known phyto-canabinoid is Delta 9 THC, so THC for short. And again, this is the component of the cannabis plant that is responsible for, getting people high when they use cannabis, but it's also known to have therapeutic effects, which I'm sure we'll talk about over the course of this session. Another cannabinoid that people know about is cannabodial, which is abbreviated to CBD. And we're really starting to see an uptick in its popularity. In fact, I wouldn't say we're starting to see to see an uptick in its popularity. It is popular right now. And part of the reason why it's so popular is because unlike THC, it is not intoxicating, and there are several hints suggesting that it might be therapeutic
适用于广泛的适应症。你提到的其他大麻素还有CBG（大麻萜酚），我想你可能还提到了CBN（大麻酚）或CBC（大麻色烯），所以有很多不同的大麻素正在向那些对这种植物的药用特性感兴趣的人进行营销。除了这些大麻素，大麻植物中还有萜烯和黄酮类化合物。萜烯和黄酮类化合物并非大麻植物所独有。但人们认为，这些不同的化学物质——同样，大麻植物中有超过100种化学物质——可能会增加其潜在的治疗效果。那么这些产品是如何监管的呢？
for a wide range of indications. Other cannabinoids you mentioned are CBG, cannabigerol, and I think that you might have also mentioned CBN or CBC, and so there are many different cannabinoids that are being marketed to people who are interested in the medicinal properties of this plant. And in addition to those cannabinoids, there are also turpines and flavonoids in the cannabis plant. And turpines and flavonoids are not unique to the cannabis plant. But it is thought that these different chemicals, again, over 100 chemicals in the cannabis plant, might add to its potential therapeutic effects. So how are each of these regulated?
它们都是合法的吗？还是非法的？目前的形势是怎样的？是的，目前的形势确实非常令人困惑。在美国，大麻（即含有超过0.3% THC的大麻植物）在联邦层面仍被视为非法。好的，再说一次，这是指含有可测量量THC的大麻植物，政府认为它可能具有有害影响或可能具有滥用潜力，等等。然而，尽管大麻在联邦层面是非法的，正如你之前提到的，它在37个州
Are all of these legal, illegal? what does the landscape look like right now? Yeah, so the landscape is actually really confusing right now. Right now in the United States, marijuana, which is cannabis that has more than 0.3% THC in it, is still considered to be federally illegal. Okay, so again, this is the cannabis plant that has measurable amounts of THC that the government thinks might be have detrimental effects or might have abuse potential, so on and so forth. However, even though marijuana is federally illegal, as you mentioned before, it is legal in 37 states
用于医疗用途是合法的。所以，各州在对待大麻的问题上制定了自己的政策。因此，37个州加上华盛顿特区已经将这种含有可测量量THC的大麻植物用于治疗目的的使用合法化了。在这37个州中，有17个州加上华盛顿特区将大麻（含有超过0.3% THC的大麻）用于非医疗用途合法化了。有些人称之为成人使用，有些人称之为娱乐使用，但本质上，这并非专门用于医疗目的。因此，我们有这样的法律地位，在联邦层面和州层面对于
for medical use. So again, states have developed their own policies with respect to marijuana. So 37 states plus Washington, D.C., have legalized the use of marijuana of this cannabis plant, with measurable amounts of THC in it for therapeutic purposes. Of these 37 states, there are 17 plus Washington, D.C, that have legalized marijuana, cannabis, with more than 0.3% THC, for non-medical use. And so some people call this adult use or some people call this recreational use, but it's essentially use that is not specifically for medical purposes. So we have that legal standing, which differs on the federal level and the state level for
含有可测量量THC的大麻（也称为大麻）存在差异。然后我们有THC含量非常非常低的大麻，政府称之为工业大麻（hemp）。2018年，一项法案获得通过，实质上将工业大麻合法化了。所以这是THC含量极低的大麻。因此，在联邦层面，工业大麻或THC含量低于0.3%的大麻现在是合法的。某些州对于如何监管这些不同的植物以及来自这些植物的产品有不同的监管框架。如果你身处一个医疗大麻合法的州，这意味着你的医生可以为你开具或推荐使用大麻的适应症类型。这一点也各不相同。
cannabis that's also called marijuana with measurable amounts of THC. Then we have cannabis that has very, very low levels of THC that the government refers to as hemp. And in 2018, a bill was passed that essentially legalized hemp. So this is cannabis with very low levels of THC. So at a federal level, hemp or cannabis with lower than 0.3% T.C is now legal. And certain states have different regulatory frameworks for how these different plants and the products that come from these plants are regulated. If you're in a medical state, that means that what types of indications you can get marijuana prescribed or recommended from your physician. And this varies too.
例如，加利福尼亚州在1996年将医用大麻合法化。我相信有13种适应症，医生可以推荐使用医用大麻，包括第13种适应症，本质上是如果你的医生认为你可能会从中受益。其他州对医用大麻的监管要严格得多。所以现在，我们在美国看到的是一个真正的拼凑体，各州层面的法律框架各不相同，而在联邦层面，关于这些产品如何监管、这种植物如何监管，几乎没有什么联邦监督。这非常复杂和令人困惑，但让我们谈谈联邦层面和你所做的工作，因为大麻在《受控物质法案》下被列为一级（Schedule I）物质。
So, for example, California legalized medical cannabis in 1996. And I believe that there are 12 indications for which your physician can recommend the use of medical cannabis, including a 13th indication, which essentially is if your physician thinks that you might benefit from it. Other states have much more stricter regulations with respect to medical cannabis. And so right now, what we're seeing across the United States is really a patchwork. of legal frameworks at the level of the state with very little federal oversight with respect to how are these products, how is this plant being regulated from a federal standpoint? That's very complicated and confusing, but let's talk at the federal level and the work that you do because marijuana is classified as a Schedule I substance under the Controlled Substances Act.
所以这对你的研究有影响，对吧？我的意思是，如果大麻在联邦层面是非法的，你是如何进行大麻研究的？金，这是一个非常重要的问题，人们有时会在这里被绊倒。所以人们认为，因为大麻（再次强调，这是含有超过0.3% THC的大麻植物）被列为一级物质，意味着它没有被认可的治疗用途，并且具有很高的滥用风险。因为政府将其归入一级类别，即联邦非法，人们认为研究它几乎是不可能的，但事实并非如此。特别有趣的是，
So that has an impact on your research, right? I mean, how do you, how are you able to do research on marijuana if it's federally illegal? Kim, this is a really important point that sometimes people get tripped up about. So people think that because marijuana, again, this is the cannabis plant with more than 0.3% THC, because marijuana is what's called Schedule 1, meaning that it has no appropriated. approved therapeutic use, and it has high risk for abuse. Because the government has put this in this Schedule I category, so federally illegal, people think that it is pretty much impossible to research, but this really isn't the case. And what's especially interesting to note is that
因为人们认为它在联邦层面是非法的，我们在美国无法研究它，人们倾向于认为其他国家比我们更能研究大麻，因为这种法律地位。但事实是，虽然在实验室里研究一种联邦非法物质，在我的案例中，实际上是在实验室里将其给予志愿者，这确实很困难，但并非不可能。因此，为了进行这项研究，必须获得多种监管批准。所以我必须拥有一个一级注册许可，即执照，才能接收这种一级材料——大麻。我必须拥有这个执照才能储存它，然后才能在
because people think that it's federally illegal and we cannot research it in the United States, people have a tendency to believe that other countries are able to study marijuana more than we can because of this legal standing. But the truth is, is that while it's very challenging to study a federally illegal substance in the laboratory and in my case to actually administer it to volunteers in the laboratory, it's difficult to do this. It is not impossible. So there are many types of regulatory approvals that have to be obtained in order to do this research. So I have to have a Schedule I registration, a license, to be able to receive this Schedule I material, marijuana. I have to have this license to be able to store it, and then also to be able to use it in
研究中使用它。现在，一个关键的问题是，如果它在联邦层面是非法的，作为一名研究人员，我实际上从哪里获得研究药物？如果我有兴趣研究大麻，我从哪里得到它？如果我拥有储存和使用它的执照或注册，我从哪里得到它？直到最近，美国在联邦层面只有唯一一个获准种植和生产大麻的来源。这是一个位于密西西比州的农场，密西西比大学，
research. Now, a critical question to ask is, well, if it's federally illegal, where, as a researcher, do I actually get the study drug? If I'm interested in studying marijuana, where do I get it from? So what if I have a license or a registration to be able to store it and use it? Where do I get it from? And so up until very recently, there was only one source in the United States that was allowed at the federal level to cultivate and produce marijuana. This was a farm in Mississippi, University of Mississippi,
他们基本上为美国正在进行的所有大麻研究提供了研究药物。他们几十年来一直这样做，从1970年之前就开始了。他们能够创造出一种研究人员可以使用的产品，即大麻产品，其中含有不同水平的不同化学物质、不同的大麻素。重要的是，作为一名研究人员，你知道，我为一名参与者和一名志愿者使用的大麻，我希望确保那种大麻与我在同一项研究中为下一位志愿者使用的大麻非常、非常相似，几乎完全相同。因此，密西西比大学能够生产这种产品，它既可靠又一致，也达到了FDA规定的用于人类
and they essentially provided the study drug for all the marijuana studies that were happening in the United States. And they have been doing this for decades since before 1970. And they were able to create a product, marijuana product, that researchers could use that had different levels of different chemicals, different cannabinoids in it. And importantly, as a, a researcher, you know, the marijuana that I use for one participant and one volunteer, I want to make sure that that marijuana is very, very similar, almost identical to the marijuana that I use in the next volunteer in that same study. And so the University of Mississippi was able to produce this product and it was able to be reliable and consistent and also reached the standards for human
研究的标准。所以这是一个非常重要的。所以这是一项艰巨的任务，他们确实帮助提供了当时美国几乎所有大麻研究都在使用的大麻研究药物。现在，在2021年，缉毒局（DEA）向更多的种植者和培育者发放了执照。这真的很令人兴奋，因为在2016年，DEA开放了新种植者和生产者的申请，但DEA花了五年时间才审阅完所有的申请，并筛选出他们将要发放执照的对象。所以现在我们处于这样一个阶段，有更多的培育者
research as put forth by the FDA. So this was a very important. So this was a tremendous undertaking, and they really helped to provide the study drug that essentially all studies in the United States of marijuana were using at the time. Now, in 2021, the Drug Enforcement Administration granted licenses to additional growers and cultivators. So this was really exciting because in 2016, the DEA opened up for application. of new growers and producers, but it took five years until the DEA was able to go through all the applications and be able to sift through which ones they were going to be able to grant a license to. And so right now we're at a point where there are additional cultivators
他们致力于制造比密西西比大学现有产品更多样化的产品，或者研究利基产品或利基大麻素，以便他们能够为研究人员提供可用于研究的全部研究材料，并提出这样一个问题：大麻对大脑和身体有什么影响？我想回到那个问题，但在我们这样做之前，我的另一个问题是，你正在研究的是在政府监督下创造的东西，这与我如果走进华盛顿特区市中心的一家药房，
who are working on making more diverse products, let's say, than what the University of Mississippi has available, or looking at niche products or niche cannabinoids, so that they can be able to provide researchers a full breadth of study material that can be used for research and asking the question, what is the impact of cannabis on brain and body? I want to get back to that question, but before we do, my other question is this, which is you're studying something that was created under government supervision, which isn't really the same thing as, say, I could buy if I went into downtown D.C. to a dispensary,
买一些产品真的不是一回事。那么它们具有可比性吗？我的意思是，如果你正在研究那种特定类型的THC，即你在联邦法律下通过你拥有的执照获得的大麻素，它真的适用于如果我正在购买食品或购买花蕾，
and bought some products there. So is it comparable? I mean, if you're doing research on that particular type of THC, the cannabinoids that you're getting under federal law with the license that you have, is it really applicable to what's happening to me if I'm buying edibles or getting buds
或者我在药房买的任何东西时发生的情况吗？是的，所以这本质上是一个困境。我现在在UCLA，如果我站起来看向窗外，我可以看到窗外有两家药房。我知道那些药房里的东西和我正在实验室里研究的产品类型非常不同。那么，我在实验室里研究的东西，可以推广到人们正在使用的东西上吗？我们认为，首先，人们正在使用的产品类型在不断演变，而且演变速度很快。
or whatever I might be buying at a dispensary? Right, and so this is a quandary essentially. So I'm at UCLA right now, and if I stood up and looked out my window, I could see two dispensaries out of my window. And I know that what's in those dispensaries is very different than the type of products that I am studying in the laboratory. Now, is what I'm studying in the laboratory, can it be generalized to what people are using? And we believe that, first of all, the types of products that people are using are ever evolving and they are evolving quickly.
所以我们正在努力研究人们正在使用的产品类型，但我们明白，跟上行业和这些产品的商业化步伐是非常困难的。话虽如此，有一些创造性的方法可以基本上了解人们正在使用的一些最常见的产品。所以，金，你提到14%的人口正在口服使用大麻。所以他们正在使用食品。那么我们能在实验室里研究这个吗？我们能研究人们吸食大麻或吸入大麻（这是人们使用大麻最流行的方式）与口服方式之间的差异吗？我们确实有方法可以在实验室里以一种非常受控和系统的方式来解决这个问题。
So we are attempting to be able to study the types of products that people are using, but we understand that it's very difficult to keep up with the industry and with commercialization of these products. That being said, there are creative ways to be able to essentially understand what are some of the most common products that people are using. So, Kim, you mentioned that 14% of the population are using cannabis orally. So they're using edible products. So can we study that in the lab? Can we study differences between how people smoke cannabis or inhale cannabis, which is the most popular way that people use cannabis versus oral? And there are ways that we can actually address this in the lab in a very controlled and systematic way.
现在，还有一点值得考虑的是，虽然人们经常说我们从密西西比州或一些其他持牌种植者那里获得的产品或研究药物可能与人们在药房里获得的产品不完全相同。有一点要记住，即使我们查看药房产品，我可以向你保证，如果我能从我窗外看到的药房里获得药房产品，它们实际上会与你在街那头的药房里买到的药房产品不同，金，对吧？因为每个州都有不同的法规，每个州本质上都有不同的大麻市场，因为产品不能从一个州运到另一个州，因为，再次强调，那是州际贸易，需要，你知道，
Now, something that's interesting also to consider is that while people often say the product or the study drugs that we get from Mississippi or some of these other licensed cultures, cultivators might not be identical to what people are getting in the dispensary. Something to keep in mind is that even if we were to look at dispensary products, I can guarantee you that the dispensary products that I would be able to, if I were able to get the dispensary products from the dispensaries I see outside of my window, they would actually be different, Kim, than the dispensary products that are available in your dispensary down the street, right? Because every state has different regulations and every state essentially has a different cannabis market because the products can't go from one state to the next because, again, that's interstate commerce and requires, you know,
联邦监督，对吧？所以发生的情况是，每个州都有不同类型的产品。因此，作为有兴趣研究这些产品类型的研究人员，我们的工作是了解人们正在使用的一些最受欢迎的产品，无论是用于医疗目的还是非医疗目的。我们如何找到一种方法在实验室里研究这些类型的产品，然后找出我们从哪里可以获得这些类型的产品，以便我们可以在实验室里研究它们，以获得我们可能在会议稍后讨论的一系列终点？所以，虽然我获得的产品不一定与你在药房看到的产品完全相同，但我们认为这些类型的产品可以推广到
federal oversight there, right? And so what happens is every state kind of has different types of products. So our job as researchers who are interested in looking at these types of products is to understand what are some of the most popular products that people are using, whether it be for medical purposes or for non-medical purposes. How can we figure out a way to study those types of products in the lab and then figure out where can we get those types of products so that we can study them in the laboratory for a range of endpoints that we'll talk about probably later on in the session? So while the products I get are not identical necessarily to what you are seeing in the dispensary, we think that these types of products can be generalized.
人们正在使用的产品类型。那么让我们回到我想问你的另一个问题，也就是你刚才提到的，大麻素如何作用于大脑和身体。它们影响哪些系统，为什么人们在此时此刻对使用大麻素如此感兴趣？这是两个有点不同的问题。
to the types of products that people are using. So let's go back to this other question I wanted to ask you, which is essentially what you alluded to a moment ago, how cannabinoids work on the brain and body. What systems do they affect and why are people so interested in using cannabinoids for what purposes at this point in time? These are two kind of different questions.
好的，所以第一个问题是，大麻素在大脑和身体的什么地方起作用？第二个问题是，为什么人们对使用大麻和大麻素来帮助解决一系列医疗适应症感兴趣？我认为也许这两个问题可以齐头并进，但它们也可以分开回答。所以人们认为，我认为，在一般层面上，很多人相信大麻素，
Okay, so the first question is, where do cannabinoids act in the brain and the body? And the second question is, Why are people interested in using cannabis and cannabinoids to help with a range of medical indications? I think that maybe those two questions can go hand in hand, but they can also be answered separately. So it's thought, I think, at the general level, a lot of people believe that cannabinoids,
大麻植物中的大麻素作用于我们身体自身的大麻素系统。这被称为内源性大麻素系统。意思是内源性的和内源性大麻素系统。所以我们的身体有一个与我们自身大麻素相关的系统。这个系统包含两个特定的受体，即结合药物的蛋白质，在这种情况下是我们体内的内源性化学物质，在这种情况下通常是脂质。当这些化学物质与这些受体——大麻素1受体和大麻素2受体——结合时，下游效应就会发生。
cannabinoids in the cannabis plant act on our body's own cannabinoid system. And this is called the endoc cannabinoid system. meaning endogenous and cannabinoid system. So our bodies have a system that are related to our own cannabinoids. This system comprises two specific receptors, so proteins that bind drugs, in this case are endogenous chemicals that are, in this case, are usually lipids. And when these chemicals bind to these receptors, the cannabinoid 1 and the cannabinoid 2 receptor, downstream effects happen.
并且有化学信号传导，导致各种结果。现在，大麻素受体，CB1和CB2受体，即两个主要受体，它们位于大脑中，也位于你的器官系统中。有趣的是，很多人没有意识到的是，我们大脑中有许多不同类型的受体。你的听众可能听说过多巴胺受体或血清素受体、阿片受体。大麻素受体的有趣之处在于，它是大脑中最丰富的受体，比多巴胺、血清素或阿片受体更丰富。所以这通常非常令人惊讶，因为很多人没有意识到我们的大脑中有这些受体。而且这些特定的受体正是THC结合并激活并产生其效果的受体。
And there's chemical signaling, which lead to a variety of outcomes. Now, the cannabinoid receptors, the CB1 and the CB2 receptor, so two main receptors, they're located in the brain and also in your organ systems. And what's interesting what a lot of people don't realize is that we have a lot of different types of receptors in the brain. Your audience might have heard of the dopamine receptors or the serotonum receptors, the opioid receptors. What's interesting about the cannabinoid receptor is that it is the most abundant receptor in the brain, more abundant than dopamine or serotonin or opioid receptors. And so this is usually very surprising because a lot of people don't realize that we have these in our brain. And that these specific receptors are the ones that THC bind to and activates and produces their effects.
我们还有其他受体，即大麻素2受体。大麻素2受体，再次强调，它们在大脑中的分布不如CB1受体多，但它们分布在身体的各个器官系统中。人们认为它们更多地调节身体的免疫反应。所以我们有两个受体，而且我们的身体会产生天然的化学物质，这些化学物质会与这些受体结合以产生各种效果。现在，大麻植物，大麻植物，抱歉，大麻植物，其中含有大麻素，很多人认为我在播客开头提到的所有这些不同的大麻素——CBD、THC、CBN、CBC、CBG——人们倾向于认为它们直接与
We also have other receptors, this cannabinoid two receptors. The cannabinoid two receptors, again, they're not as much located in the brain, but they're located in the body across all different organ systems. And they're thought to modulate more the immune responses of the body. So we have these two receptors, and we also have our body creates natural chemicals that bind to these receptors to produce a variety of effects. Now, the cannabinoid plant, the cannabis plant, excuse me, the cannabis plant, which has cannabinoids in it, a lot of people believe that all these different cannabinoids that I was talking about in the beginning of the podcast, CBD, THC, CBN, CBC, CBG, people have a tendency to think that they interact directly. with our cannabinoid system, our endogenous cannabinoid system, probably because, you know, they share the same terminology. We have the phyto-canabinoids and we have the indigenous cannabinoid system. But this isn't necessarily the case. So we know that THC, Delta 9-THC, does in fact directly interact with
我们的大麻素系统，我们的内源性大麻素系统相互作用。可能是因为，你知道，它们共享相同的术语。我们有植物大麻素，我们有内源性大麻素系统。但这并不一定是真的。所以我们知道THC，Delta-9 THC，确实直接与
this endogenous cannabinoid system. It directly interacts with the CB1 receptor and the CB2 receptor. these other cannabinoids, the pharmacology, how it interacts with these receptors and other receptors in the brain and body, it's a lot less known at this point. So for example, CBD cannabodial, a lot of people think that it acts directly with our cannabinoid receptors, but it's not that clear at this point. In fact, cannabodial is thought to have tens of different ways that it interacts with all these different other receptor systems in the body. So it's important that people understand this distinction. Now, how is it that cannabis can be helpful for all these different indications that people
这个内源性大麻素系统相互作用。它直接与CB1受体和CB2受体相互作用。这些其他大麻素，其药理学，即它如何与这些受体以及大脑和身体中的其他受体相互作用，目前所知甚少。例如，CBD大麻二酚，很多人认为它直接与我们的大麻素受体相互作用，但目前还不清楚。事实上，人们认为大麻二酚有几十种不同的方式与体内所有这些其他受体系统相互作用。所以人们理解这种区别很重要。那么，大麻怎么能对人们可能正在使用的所有这些不同的适应症都有帮助呢？
might be using it? So one way, and you can think of it for just thinking about the THC and the cannabis plant, I already told you that THC acts at these two receptors, cannabinoid receptors, is the CB1 and the CB2 receptor that are abundant in the brain and the body and across organ systems. And so just by nature of the fact that THC interacts with this receptor system that's all over the body, it can potentially have an impact on disease states that impact all these different organ systems. Now, how do some of these other cannabinoids act to have medicinal properties? We're just starting to work that out at this point in time.
所以一种方式，你可以只考虑THC和大麻植物，我已经告诉你THC作用于这两个受体，大麻素受体，即CB1和CB2受体，它们在大脑、身体和各个器官系统中都很丰富。因此，仅仅因为THC与遍布全身的这个受体系统相互作用，它就可能对影响所有这些不同器官系统的疾病状态产生影响。现在，这些其他大麻素中的一些是如何发挥药用特性的呢？我们目前才刚刚开始研究这个问题。
So, for example, CBD is a big puzzle. A lot of people are using CBD for a range of indications, and it's not quite clear the science behind how CBD might be helpful for reducing anxiety or it might be helpful for reducing pain. In fact, it's not even quite clear yet in humans that CBD might be helpful for a range of the indications that people are using it for. And so this is something that we're trying to work out in our laboratory and other scientists. that are associated with the APA are also trying to work this out. And yet, the product is ubiquitous.
例如，CBD是一个巨大的谜题。很多人正在将CBD用于一系列适应症，CBD可能有助于减轻焦虑或减轻疼痛的科学依据尚不完全清楚。事实上，在人类身上，CBD是否对人们正在使用它的一系列适应症有帮助，目前还不完全清楚。所以这是我们正在实验室里努力研究的问题，与美国心理学会（APA）相关的其他科学家也在努力研究这个问题。然而，这种产品无处不在。
I mean, I have to say with CBD, for example, I have an elderly dog. We give her CBD every day. The vet said, give it to her. It's supposed to make her feel better. Does it? I don't know. You know, my father had arthritis in his leg. We got him this CBD cream.
我的意思是，以CBD为例，我不得不说，我有一只老狗。我们每天给她喂CBD。兽医说，给她喂吧。它应该能让她感觉好点。真的有效吗？我不知道。你知道，我父亲腿上有关节炎。我们给他买了这种CBD乳膏。
He used it. He said he felt better. Was it the CBD? Was it the placebo effect? Who knows, right? I mean, we don't know. We don't know, and it's going to take time to figure out, is it a placebo effect, or is it because of the CBD in that topical product? Maybe there's also another ingredient in that topical product that might actually be helpful for arthritis.
他用了。他说他感觉好多了。是CBD的作用吗？是安慰剂效应吗？谁知道呢，对吧？我的意思是，我们不知道。我们不知道，弄清楚它是安慰剂效应，还是因为那种外用产品中的CBD，需要时间。也许那种外用产品中还有另一种成分，可能实际上对关节炎有帮助。
And so we actually have a study here at UCLA where we're looking at CBD's effects specifically for rheumatoid arthritis. So we know that arthritis is related to inflammation. and we think based off of animal studies that CBD might be helpful in reducing this inflammation. And so right now we're doing a placebo-controlled study to understand this very question. And Kim, I'm in the same boat as you. I hear all the time when I'm going to parties with, you know, dinner parties with my in-laws and their friends or my parents and their friends. And I always have somebody at those parties share with me the success that they've had with CBD and their arthritis. Now, if it's placebo, does it really matter?
所以我们实际上在UCLA有一项研究，我们正在专门研究CBD对类风湿性关节炎的效果。所以我们知道关节炎与炎症有关。我们根据动物研究认为，CBD可能有助于减轻这种炎症。所以现在我们正在进行一项安慰剂对照研究来弄清楚这个问题。金，我和你处境相同。当我和我的姻亲及其朋友或我的父母及其朋友参加晚宴时，我总是听到有人与我分享他们使用CBD治疗关节炎的成功经验。现在，如果是安慰剂，这真的重要吗？
You know, like if it's in effect, if they're getting relief, if their quality of life is improving, then great. And will we ever be able to tell that that specific topical CBD cream that your dad is taking is actually more effective than placebo? I can guarantee you that we probably will not be able to get that far. But we can approximate. We can be able to say, well, you know, we can do a study. Is topical CBD helpful for our third?
你知道，如果它有效果，如果他们得到了缓解，如果他们的生活质量正在改善，那就太好了。我们是否能够证明你父亲正在使用的那种特定的外用CBD乳膏实际上比安慰剂更有效？我可以向你保证，我们可能无法做到那一步。但我们可以进行近似。我们可以说，好吧，你知道，我们可以做一项研究。外用CBD对关节炎有帮助吗？
What is the type of dose that's required? How many times does it have to be applied? If we're looking at oral administration, you know, not only can we look at the potential therapeutic effects, but we can also begin to understand, well, what are some of the potential adverse effects that we should be mindful of, right? Which is very important when we're thinking about using these products as medicine. Now, you study the differences in the way men and women respond to cannabinoids. What have you found? How do we react differently and why is it important to look at those differences? One reason why I think it's really important to look at these differences, again, is going back to consumer behavior and what are people doing. So it was interesting.
所需的剂量是多少？必须涂抹多少次？如果我们看口服给药，你知道，我们不仅可以研究潜在的治疗效果，我们还可以开始了解，好吧，我们应该注意哪些潜在的副作用，对吧？当我们考虑将这些产品用作药物时，这一点非常重要。现在，你研究了男性和女性对大麻素反应的差异。你发现了什么？我们反应有何不同，为什么观察这些差异很重要？我认为观察这些差异非常重要的一个原因，再次回到消费者行为和人们正在做什么。所以很有趣。
A couple of years ago, I read a report about how traditionally people who use cannabis, males always outweigh females two to one. For whatever reason, we can talk. about that probably in another podcast. But always males outweighed females for cannabis use. But then I started noticing that, you know, there have been several surveys of medical cannabis patients. And what I was noticing more and more was that the ratio of or the proportion of males of females were equal. Or in some cases, there were more females using medical cannabis products for indications compared to men. And it made me, realize that, okay, well, here's a significant part of the patient population that's using
几年前，我读到一份报告，关于传统上使用大麻的人，男性总是比女性多二比一。无论出于什么原因，我们可以在另一个播客中讨论这个问题。但男性使用大麻的人数总是超过女性。但我开始注意到，你知道，已经有几项关于医用大麻患者的调查。我注意到越来越多的是，男性与女性的比例是相等的。或者在某些情况下，与男性相比，有更多的女性使用医用大麻产品来治疗适应症。这让我意识到，好吧，这里有很大一部分患者群体正在使用
medical cannabis that is now female. How much work has been done in the field with respect to understanding the effects of cannabis and differences between males and females? So we've learned from animal studies that males and females are quite different in their response to specific cannabinoids. For example, in female rodents, there is a heightened sensitivity to THC's pain relieving effects. Now, there's also a heightened sensitivity to adverse effects, such as what's called abuse potential or addictive potential in female rats. So this raised the question to me.
医用大麻，现在是女性。在理解大麻的影响以及男性和女性之间的差异方面，该领域做了多少工作？我们从动物研究中了解到，男性和女性对特定大麻素的反应有很大不同。例如，在雌性啮齿动物中，对THC的止痛效果有更高的敏感性。现在，对副作用也有更高的敏感性，例如所谓的滥用潜力或成瘾潜力，在雌性大鼠中也是如此。所以这对我提出了一个问题。
Well, if we're seeing this in animals, and this doesn't happen all the time, but there is, there does tend to be some nice translation from what we see. see in animals to humans. So if we see this in animals that female rodents are a lot more sensitive to THC than males, what do we see in humans? Is that the same situation? Are females, are women more sensitive to THC's pain relieving effects than males? Could this be a reason why we're seeing more women gravitate or more women show up in surveys who are using medical cannabis for pain? And so I decided to look at that in a couple of studies that we had run looking at the effects of THC and pain in our volunteers.
好吧，如果我们能在动物身上看到这一点，虽然这并不总是发生，但确实存在一些从动物到人类的良好转化。所以如果我们看到雌性啮齿动物对THC比雄性敏感得多，我们在人类身上看到了什么？情况一样吗？女性对THC的止痛效果是否比男性更敏感？这可能是我们看到更多女性倾向于使用医用大麻治疗疼痛，或者在调查中显示更多女性使用医用大麻的原因吗？所以我决定在我们进行的一些研究中观察这一点，观察THC对我们志愿者疼痛的影响。
And what I found Kim was really interesting, actually. It was kind of the opposite of what we expected. And what we found, you know, based on the animal work, I thought that females were going to be a lot more sensitive than males to the pain relieving effects of THC. But what I found was the total opposite. What I found was that the males were sensitive to the test. pain relieving effects of THC. And when I looked at the females, essentially the females had no response.
金，我发现的情况实际上非常有趣。这与我们预期的恰恰相反。我们发现，你知道，基于动物研究，我以为女性对THC的止痛效果会比男性敏感得多。但我发现的完全相反。我发现男性对THC的止痛效果敏感。而当我观察女性时，本质上女性在我们的研究中对THC没有反应。而且，你知道，我显然很失望，因为我以为我会展示一个关于动物如何转化为人类的良好代表，但它没有奏效。我深入挖掘了一下。大约在同一时间，一些临床前研究人员，一些动物研究人员，丽贝卡·克拉夫特和她的同事拿出了一些非常
They did not show pain relief to THC in our studies. And, you know, I was clearly disappointed because I thought I was going to show a nice representation of how the animals translate to humans, but it didn't work. And I dug a little bit deeper. And around that same time, some preclinical researchers, some animal researchers, Rebecca Kraft and her colleague came out with some really. interesting data showing that although the female animals are a lot more sensitive to THC's pain relieving effects when they first get THC, after about like three weeks of repeated THC exposure,
有趣的数据显示，虽然雌性动物在第一次接触THC时对THC的止痛效果敏感得多，但在大约三周的重复THC暴露后，
the females develop tolerance at a much faster rate than the male animals. And so I went back to look at our data and I realized at the time that the people I was looking at in this particular study were people that were using cannabis every day. So, I was comparing females who are female volunteers who are being exposed to THC almost every single day, to male volunteers who are being exposed to THC almost every single day. And I was looking at their response. And I was seeing this dramatic difference in their pain relief, which kind of mapped on to what's happening in the animals. So we now have a study where we're comparing.
雌性产生耐受性的速度比雄性动物快得多。所以我回去查看了我们的数据，我意识到当时我在这项特定研究中观察的人是每天都在使用大麻的人。所以，我正在比较几乎每天都接触THC的女性志愿者，和几乎每天都接触THC的男性志愿者。我正在观察他们的反应。我看到了他们在止痛效果上的巨大差异，这与动物身上发生的情况相吻合。所以我们现在有一项研究，我们正在进行比较。
We're looking at people who use cannabis infrequently. So they wouldn't be tolerant to THC's effects, the same way that people are talking. tolerant to THC's effects if they're using it every single day. And we're comparing. We're seeing how does a pain response differ? If somebody uses THC, but they don't use cannabis regularly, they're not exposed to it every single day, well, we see that women's response is more heightened to the pain relieving effects of cannabis with THC than males in that population. And then what happens when you have people who are using cannabis every single day. Well, we see accelerated tolerance in those women.
我们正在观察那些不经常使用大麻的人。所以他们不会对THC的效果产生耐受性，就像如果他们每天都使用它，人们会对THC的效果产生耐受性一样。我们正在比较。我们正在观察疼痛反应有何不同。如果有人使用THC，但他们不经常使用大麻，他们不是每天都接触它，好吧，我们看到女性对含有THC的大麻的止痛效果的反应比该人群中的男性更强烈。然后，当你有每天都在使用大麻的人时会发生什么？好吧，我们看到那些女性产生了加速的耐受性。
So in other words, will we see that in women who are using cannabis every day, will they essentially not show the pain relieving effects of THC compared to men? And so this has become a really important question to ask because as we're seeing, we're continuing to see that more women are using cannabis specifically for pain. And in fact, there are products that are geared towards females, towards women, specifically for issues related to women's health. And so what are the impact of those products in women? Will they potentially be effective for those indications that people think they might be effective for?
换句话说，我们会看到每天使用大麻的女性，与男性相比，她们基本上不会表现出THC的止痛效果吗？所以这已经成为一个非常重要的问题，因为正如我们所看到的，我们继续看到更多的女性专门使用大麻来治疗疼痛。事实上，有一些产品是专门针对女性的，针对女性健康相关的问题。那么这些产品对女性的影响是什么？它们对人们认为可能有效的那些适应症是否可能有效？
Will there be faster rates of tolerance? So should people be more mindful of how much THC they're using? should they take breaks to help reduce any tolerance over time? How did their responses compare to men's responses? And then also on the flip side, what about some adverse effects? So there was an interesting paper put out by Collies at Johns Hopkins, who showed that females, again, women who are not regularly exposed to cannabis, when they take THC, either inhaled or when they use it orally, and you compare them to men, they actually show a heightened reaction to the anxiety promoting qualities of THC. So in their sample, in that sample, they show that females were more susceptible to, you know,
耐受性产生的速度会更快吗？所以人们是否应该更注意他们使用了多少THC？他们是否应该休息一下以帮助减少随时间产生的任何耐受性？她们的反应与男性的反应相比如何？然后另一方面，副作用又如何呢？所以约翰霍普金斯大学的科利斯发表了一篇有趣的论文，表明女性，再次强调，不经常接触大麻的女性，当她们服用THC时，无论是吸入还是口服，当你把她们和男性进行比较时，她们实际上对THC的致焦虑特性表现出更强烈的反应。所以，在他们的样本中，在那个样本中，他们表明女性更容易受到，你知道，
how you can become more anxious when you use cannabis. And those audience members who are listening right now, they might have had that experience where even though a lot of people use cannabis with THC to help reduce anxiety, sometimes it actually increases anxiety. And so if that's an effect that we're seeing in females, again, that should really help to guide how women might approach cannabis and THC for therapeutic use. You mentioned working with subjects who are taking THC every day, which raises a question in my mind, which is, can marijuana cannabinoids be addictive? I mean, is that a risk? How does this compare to other substances such as alcohol, or do you become dependent or addicted?
你使用大麻时可能会变得更加焦虑。现在正在收听的听众可能也有过这样的经历：尽管很多人使用含四氢大麻酚（THC）的大麻来帮助减轻焦虑，但有时它实际上会增加焦虑。如果这是我们在女性身上观察到的效果，那么这确实应该有助于指导女性如何将大麻和THC用于治疗目的。你提到过与每天服用THC的受试者合作，这让我产生了一个疑问，那就是大麻素会让人上瘾吗？我的意思是，这是一种风险吗？这与其他物质（如酒精）相比如何？你会产生依赖或成瘾吗？
I mean, there is a difference. Right. And so generally speaking, when we talk about problematic cannabis use, we usually refer to a DSM-5 diagnosis, so a psychiatric diagnosis of what's called cannabis use disorder. Now, cannabis use disorder can be diagnosed when somebody hits criteria for meeting a range of symptoms that are markers of cannabis use disorder. And so one prominent symptom that people have, if they have cannabis use disorder, one symptom is developing what's called dependence, right? So in a subset of the population that uses cannabis with high frequency, when they stop using cannabis, Specifically cannabis with THC, by the way. We can talk about CBD in a second.
我的意思是，这确实有区别。没错。所以总的来说，当我们谈论有问题的大麻使用时，我们通常指的是DSM-5诊断，也就是所谓的“大麻使用障碍”的心理学诊断。当某人符合一系列作为大麻使用障碍标志的症状标准时，就可以诊断为大麻使用障碍。人们如果患有大麻使用障碍，一个突出的症状就是产生所谓的依赖性，对吧？所以，在经常使用大麻的特定人群中，当他们停止使用大麻时——顺便说一下，特指含THC的大麻。我们可以稍后再谈CBD。
But cannabis with THC, that primary intoxicating component of the cannabis plant, in a subset of the population that uses cannabis regularly, every day, essentially, when they stop using it, they might experience symptoms of withdrawal. And that's a hallmark of what dependence is. And so some of these symptoms of withdrawal are more subtle than others, but essentially some core features of withdrawal include reduced appetite, disruptions in sleep, irritability. Those are some of the core features of withdrawal.
但是对于含THC的大麻，也就是大麻植物中主要的致幻成分，在经常（基本上是每天）使用大麻的特定人群中，当他们停止使用时，可能会出现戒断症状。这是依赖性的一个标志。其中一些戒断症状比其他症状更微妙，但本质上，戒断的一些核心特征包括食欲减退、睡眠障碍、易怒。这些都是戒断的一些核心特征。
Now, what's interesting is that withdrawal doesn't necessarily happen right away. So you can imagine that other types of substances that can induce dependence, such as opioids, you know, withdrawal can happen pretty soon after somebody abstains from using that type of product. With cannabis, it's a little bit different. It can take a day to start those withdrawal symptoms, and the withdrawal symptoms don't necessarily peak until three days after abstinence. And this is based off of studies that were done at University of Columbia, Columbia University, with Meg Haney and her group. And they showed very elegantly that you can get consistent withdrawal symptoms in people who are using very regularly and who abstain. Now, for the most part, people who are using cannabis every day, they're not necessarily going to come into contact with these withdrawal symptoms because they are using cannabis more frequently than required to actually experience withdrawal.
有趣的是，戒断反应并不一定会立即发生。你可以想象，其他类型的能引起依赖的物质，如阿片类药物，在停止使用该类产品后不久就会出现戒断反应。大麻则有点不同。它可能需要一天时间才会开始出现戒断症状，而且戒断症状不一定会立即达到顶峰，通常在停止使用三天后才会达到顶峰。这是基于哥伦比亚大学Meg Haney及其团队所做的研究。他们非常优雅地证明了，在经常使用并停止使用的人群中，确实会出现持续的戒断症状。现在，大多数每天使用大麻的人，并不一定会接触到这些戒断症状，因为他们使用大麻的频率比实际经历戒断所需的频率要高。
So frequently, people don't necessarily endorse those withdrawal symptoms unless they've had a period of abstinence. Other types of symptoms that are hallmarks of cannabis use disorder involve tolerance. So is more cannabis or more THC required over time to achieve a certain effect? Okay. So this is tolerance like what we just talked about before where the female animals required more THC to get that analgesic response, the pain relieving response when they were exposed to THC every single day. So that's an example of tolerance.
因此，人们通常不会表现出这些戒断症状，除非他们经历了一段戒断期。大麻使用障碍的其他标志性症状涉及耐受性。也就是说，随着时间的推移，是否需要更多的大麻或更多的THC才能达到某种效果？好的。这就是我们刚才谈到的耐受性，即雌性动物每天接触THC后，需要更多的THC才能获得那种镇痛反应，即缓解疼痛的反应。这就是耐受性的一个例子。
Other examples of does your cannabis use interfere with your everyday activities? is it infringing on your professional life and your personal life? And so there are a number of other symptoms that are hallmarks of cannabis use disorder. Now, people can have cannabis use disorder and only endorse two of these symptoms. And so they would only have mild cannabis use disorder, whereas other people might endorse many more symptoms, and then they might be classified as having severe cannabis use disorder. And it really becomes an issue when a patient, with cannabis use disorder wants to try and cut down.
其他例子包括：你的大麻使用是否干扰了你的日常活动？它是否侵犯了你的职业生活和个人生活？还有许多其他症状是大麻使用障碍的标志。人们可能患有大麻使用障碍，但只表现出其中两种症状。那么他们就只有轻度的大麻使用障碍，而其他人可能会表现出更多的症状，然后他们可能会被归类为患有严重的大麻使用障碍。当患有大麻使用障碍的患者想要尝试减少使用时，这确实成为了一个问题。
Once to try and cut down their cannabis use, they're noticing that it's causing issues in their personal life or professional life. They're developing withdrawal symptoms when they stop using it. And at this point in time, there actually isn't a FDA-approved medication, a pharmacotherapy, to be able to help people who have cannabis use disorder.
一旦想要尝试减少大麻使用，他们会注意到这正在导致个人生活或职业生活出现问题。当他们停止使用时，他们会出现戒断症状。而目前，实际上还没有FDA批准的药物或药物疗法来帮助患有大麻使用障碍的人。
So unlike alcohol use disorder, or unlike opioid use disorder, or people who want to cut down on smoking cigarettes, there are pharmacological strategies to help with those use disorders. For cannabis use disorder, we're not there yet. We do not have a treatment that's been approved to help with people who want to cut down with their cannabis use. So around the time that I was in college, which was a long time ago,
所以与酒精使用障碍、阿片类药物使用障碍或想要戒烟的人不同，有药物策略可以帮助治疗这些使用障碍。对于大麻使用障碍，我们还没有做到这一点。我们还没有一种被批准的治疗方法来帮助那些想要减少大麻使用的人。所以在我上大学的时候，那是很久以前的事了，
one of the things that we would be warned about regarding marijuana was it was a gateway drug, that it was going to open the door to your doing terrible things. And some of our listeners may remember the movie, Reefer Madness. You know, some really bad things were going to happen to you. Is there any truth to that? Is cannabis somehow different from other drugs that is a gateway to you're doing something even more addictive, perhaps? Right. So I think that the fear was that, you know, if you use cannabis, then you're going to be led down this pathway. You're going to use harder drugs. And you're going to, you know, reach a point of no return, essentially. And I think at this point, we can say that this is not a cannabis thing. You know, if you look at other abuse substances,
关于大麻，我们被警告的一件事是它是一种入门毒品，它会为你做可怕的事情打开大门。我们的一些听众可能还记得电影《大麻狂热》。你知道，一些非常糟糕的事情会发生在你身上。这有什么道理吗？大麻是否在某种程度上不同于其他毒品，是让你做更令人上瘾的事情的门户？没错。所以我认为当时的恐惧是，你知道，如果你使用大麻，那么你就会被引导走上这条道路。你会使用更硬的毒品。而且你基本上会到达一个无法回头的地步。我认为在这一点上，我们可以说这不是大麻特有的问题。你知道，如果你看看其他滥用物质，
let's say alcohol or tobacco and other environmental and social factors that go into what contributes to somebody initiating a certain, initiating use of a certain substance and continuing their use. We know that there are a lot of different variables that go into play here, that it is not just cannabis, that, you know, cannabis, if somebody is using cannabis at a very young age, what are other factors that are happening there that might also increase the chances that they will be exposed to other substances of abuse and continue to use those other substance of abuse? So I think we can say that, you know, an animal model has shown this as well where THC isn't necessarily special. So there are other drugs where if a animal is exposed to that particular drug early in life and then expose an adulthood to another novel substance of abuse, you know, that will increase their drug taking of that other novel substance of abuse.
比如酒精或烟草，以及其他导致某人开始使用某种物质并继续使用的环境和社会因素。我们知道，这里有很多不同的变量在起作用，不仅仅是大麻。你知道，如果某人在很小的年纪就开始使用大麻，那么还有哪些其他因素在起作用，也可能增加他们接触其他滥用物质并继续使用这些其他滥用物质的机会？所以我认为我们可以说，动物模型也显示了这一点，THC并不一定是特殊的。所以还有其他药物，如果动物在生命早期接触过那种特定的药物，然后在成年后接触到另一种新的滥用物质，你知道，这会增加他们对那种其他新的滥用物质的摄入。
So there are a lot of other factors that go into substance use in populations, even. even beyond just what types of substances that individual is exposed to. Again, I think social, environmental variables play a significant role in how people initiate substance use and if they maintain that substance use to a point where it adversely affects their life. So last question, just to wrap up, what are the next big, most important research questions that we need to answer to keep up with what's happening in the world and the marketplace around cannabis?
因此，即使在人群中，还有许多其他因素会影响物质使用，甚至不仅仅是该个体接触的物质类型。同样，我认为社会和环境变量在人们如何开始使用物质以及他们是否维持这种使用到对其生活产生不利影响的程度方面起着重要作用。所以最后一个问题，总结一下，为了跟上大麻在世界和市场上的发展，我们需要回答的下一个重大、最重要的研究问题是什么？
I think that some of the biggest questions that really need to be answered is first getting a sense of what are people using? What are people using in the United States at what frequency? What is their pattern of use? What are they using these types of cannabis and cannabis-related products for? What are the types of populations that we should be most interested in? For example, vulnerable populations, pregnant women. Are pregnant women using cannabis when they are pregnant to help with X, Y, and Z condition, nausea, vomiting? Are they using it more than traditional medications? That is a really important question to ask. Older adults, so we see a significant increase in the rates of cannabis use among people age 55 and older. What are older adults using? What is the frequency of use in this population. In the general population, what are some of the other products that are coming out that seem to be taking hold? So of course, there's going to be, you know,
我认为最需要回答的一些最大问题是，首先要了解人们在用什么？人们在美国的使用频率是多少？他们的使用模式是什么？他们使用这些类型的大麻和大麻相关产品是为了什么？我们应该最关注哪些类型的人群？例如，弱势群体、孕妇。孕妇在怀孕时是否使用大麻来帮助缓解X、Y和Z状况，如恶心、呕吐？她们使用它的频率是否比传统药物更高？这是一个非常重要的问题。老年人，我们看到55岁及以上人群的大麻使用率显著增加。老年人在使用什么？这个人群的使用频率是多少？在普通人群中，还有哪些似乎正在流行的新产品？当然，会有，你知道，
a little fad here or there. But then other times there are products that are being produced that are not just a fad. They become a trend. For example, high potency cannabis products. These extracts that are essentially made from the cannabis plant that are almost 100% THC. And And they're available at dispensaries in many different states around the country. So at first, I think some people thought maybe this was just a fleeting fad and maybe, you know, people were experimenting with it. But from where we stand at UCLA, we interview a lot of people who use cannabis on a daily basis. And we're finding that, no, this is not a fad. People are using these extracts, these high potency extracts frequently, almost every day.
这里或那里有一点狂热。但有时生产的产品不仅仅是狂热。它们成为了一种趋势。例如，高浓度大麻产品。这些基本上由大麻植物制成的提取物，几乎是100%的THC。它们在全国许多不同州的药房都有售。所以起初，我认为有些人可能认为这只是昙花一现的狂热，也许，你知道，人们只是在尝试它。但从我们在加州大学洛杉矶分校的角度来看，我们采访了很多每天使用大麻的人。我们发现，不，这不是狂热。人们经常使用这些提取物，这些高浓度提取物，几乎每天都在使用。
And they've been using them for a couple of years at this point. what are the effects in real time? What happens when somebody uses these high potency extracts, these high potency dabs, wax shatter? And then over the long term, what are some of the consequences? One would guess that maybe the effects would look very different than, you know, smoking a cannabis cigarette, which has less milligrams of fewer milligrams of THC in it. But we actually don't know.
而且到目前为止，他们已经使用它们几年了。实时效果是什么？当有人使用这些高浓度提取物，这些高浓度的dab、蜡、碎块时会发生什么？从长远来看，会有什么后果？人们可能会猜测，效果看起来会与吸食大麻烟卷非常不同，因为大麻烟卷中THC的毫克数较少。但我们实际上并不知道。
And so this is a really important empirical question that we need to ask. And then with respect to therapeutic effects, what are some of the statistics related to the most popular indications for which people are using cannabis? And what type of cannabis products? So we know that people are using cannabis for three specific indications, at least the most popular reasons that people use cannabis is pain, anxiety, and to help with sleep. Are people using more CBD for these indications? How are they using it? Are they smoking?
所以这是一个我们需要提出的非常重要的实证问题。关于治疗效果，与人们使用大麻最流行的适应症相关的一些统计数据是什么？以及什么类型的大麻产品？我们知道人们使用大麻有三个特定的适应症，至少人们使用大麻最流行的原因是疼痛、焦虑和帮助睡眠。人们是否为这些适应症使用了更多的CBD？他们是如何使用的？他们是在吸食吗？
Are they using it orally? Are there other ways that people are using it? And so first, when we get a finger on the pulse of what people are doing, then we can start drilling down and asking the important questions that are really rooted in filling in the holes with respect to what is the information we can share with people that is most relevant. What is the information that we can tell them about the potential adverse effects and the potential therapeutic effects? and also how can we share this information to, let's say, practitioners who are talking to their patients on a daily basis and whose patients are telling them that they're using X, Y, and Z cannabis product for this indication. And this is a really important area that I think we're going to see grow over time. But again, it's going to be hard to catch up with the cannabis marketplace and the types of products that are available. And so at this point in time, we just have to figure out what are the most pressing.
他们是口服使用吗？还有其他使用方式吗？所以首先，当我们掌握了人们在做什么的脉搏时，我们就可以开始深入研究并提出重要的问题，这些问题真正扎根于填补空白，即我们可以与人们分享什么是最相关的信息。关于潜在的不良反应和潜在的治疗效果，我们可以告诉他们什么信息？以及我们如何与每天与患者交谈的从业者分享这些信息，他们的患者告诉他们他们正在使用X、Y和Z大麻产品来治疗这种适应症。这是一个非常重要的领域，我认为我们会看到它随着时间的推移而增长。但同样，要赶上大麻市场和现有产品的类型将是困难的。所以目前，我们只需要找出最紧迫的问题。
questions to ask based off of what are the most popular or prevalent modes of use and for what indications. Well, this is all really fascinating. You're right there on the cutting edge of something that is just sweeping our country. And I thank you for the work that you're doing and for joining me today. Thank you, Dr. Cooper. Thank you so much, Ken. This is really fun. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you hear, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at apa.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris
基于最流行或最普遍的使用方式和适应症来提出问题。好吧，这一切真的非常迷人。你正处于席卷我们国家的事物的最前沿。我感谢你所做的工作以及今天加入我。谢谢你，Cooper博士。非常感谢，Ken。这真的很有趣。你可以在我们的网站www.speakingofpsychology.org或Apple、Stitcher或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。如果你喜欢你听到的内容，请给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以发电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由Lee Weinerman制作。我们的声音编辑是Chris
Kondayan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Kondayan。感谢收听。代表美国心理学会，我是Kim Mills。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。